Véronique prince Michel coger Millet
Nicolas bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir tour de
table rapide sur l'augmentation qui sera
concrétisé le 1er mai prochain au Québec
du salaire minimum ont hausse de 1
dollar 15-25 l'Ontario est à 15-50
Véronique c'était attendu disons et
demandez les syndicats demandaient 18
ans oui alors le gouvernement
aujourd'hui ne doit quand même pas
surprendre si les gens sont pas au
plafond avec cette annonce là parce
qu'elle paraît un peu en décalage alors
que l'Ontario le fait dans la dernière
année et surtout surtout monsieur le
Gaulle lui-même au mois de décembre
dernier en pleine période de questions
alors qu'il est en échange avec Gabriel
Nadaud Dubois lui-même a reconnu que
même à 18 $ ce n'était pas suffisant
surtout avec des enfants alors en
faisant cette déclaration là puis après
son ministre qui vient annoncer 15
dollars 25 dollars c'est pas surprenant
que les groupes disent ouais mais c'est
18 qu'il faut même le Premier ministre
le reconnu décembre dernier Emilie
l'argumentaire et je faisais un débat
cette semaine au Téléjournal là-dessus
l'argumentaire du monde des affaires du
jour le même ils disent vous pouvez oui
aller à 18 mais il y a des entreprises
qui pourront pas suivre
merci les entreprises
je pense que le contexte le contexte a
fait en sorte que en fait si on fait pas
les gens qu'on considérablement même
pour les chefs d'entreprise enfin le
secteur c'est rendu un problème ceci dit
donc les personnes qui acceptent de
travailler à des salaires aussi bas
c'est souvent les personnes qui ont un
ensemble de vulnérabilité qui font qu'il
fasse pas se trouver du travail ailleurs
donc ça va toucher les personnes qui
avaient moins de loisirs de chercher
d'autres endroits que les gens dans des
secteurs qui sont peu touchés par la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre de 15$ depuis
des années maintenant qui arrive c'est
un peu c'est en fait c'est trop tard
puis c'est sûr que ça va ça va susciter
des mobilisations
il y a aussi l'inflation qui a été dans
la dernière année absolument
considérable est-ce sur les biens
essentiels comme l'alimentation elle
reste beaucoup plus élevée que la hausse
du soleil au minimum donc on peut dire
c'est une autre historique mais oui
c'est vrai que ça va la dernière fois
qu'on dépasse 15 alarmes mais à la fin
c'était pas suffisant et pour les gens
qui doivent travailler à ce salaire là
et il y en a encore beaucoup
contrairement à ce qu'on passe ça veut
dire une année très difficile à être
capable de rejoindre les deux bouts
c'est évident c'est presque 300
000 personnes beaucoup des femmes il y a
et l'autre argument qu'on entend
beaucoup oui c'est vrai qu'il y a des
étudiants là-dedans qui habitent chez
leurs parents à peu près la moitié un
peu moins que la moitié mais voilà ça
touche bon et aussi le salaire minimum
m'a évidemment un impact sur toute la
chaîne ensuite là et ça en principe ça
ose le salaire de tout le monde avoir
monsieur Legault ce matin s'intéressant
Michel sait je peux vous faire
grossir la tête mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il vous répondait à votre chronique
qui a pas aimé ce matin mais entre
autres vous mais toute la semaine c'est
vrai que depuis le départ de ce fibrochu
ouais donc vous êtes plusieurs mais
drel BB drel votre chronique dans la
presse matin
parce que quand je vois le chef de
cabinet du premier ministre Twitter une
chronique enzyme Michel vous avez pas
tout à fait compris je me dis on a dû
discuter seul le matin mais bon c'est
pas sur vous là je veux pas parler de
vous je parlais de l'Hydro-Québec je
vais vous faire entendre monsieur
Legault qui dit écoutez là il y a pas
deux camps au Québec on est tous pour le
développement on veut pas gaspiller
l'hydroélectricité mais en même temps
c'est un levier de développement
économique extraordinaire qu'on veut pas
bazarder à des entreprises à des prix
trop bas non plus alors il a voulu
recadrer le message
puis là on a une opportunité
extraordinaire exceptionnel en même
temps qu'on décarbonne le Québec de
créer des nouvelles entreprises des
nouveaux secteurs qui vont enrichir le
Québec et les Québécois
c'est arrivé dans le passé ok que des
gouvernements
ont signé des contrats ou les rabais qui
étaient donnés en électricité était
inférieur aux revenus additionnels le
gouvernement du Québec c'est arrivé donc
ce fibrochu avait raison de dire
attention de pas devenir le Dollarama
mais il y a une chose qui était claire
entre autres au mois de décembre on a eu
une rencontre on était tous d'accord
pour dire jamais Hydro-Québec doit
signer un contrat si les rabais qui est
donné est supérieur aux revenus
additionnels au gouvernement du Québec
donc monsieur le Gaudi c'est vrai dans
le passé que les alumineries entre
autres Véronique on a peut-être exagéré
mais là on veut attirer des entreprises
qui vont bien payer les gens qui vont
développer toute la filière dont vous
parliez dans cette excellent reportage
hier Véronique sur becancourt le
gouvernement rêve d'Ivoire développé un
parc industriel extraordinaire pour des
pièces de batterie c'est un peu le lac
de monsieur Legault c'est ça qui veut
faire en tout cas dans les prochaines
années oui d'autant plus que nos
compétiteurs selon le ministre
Pierrefitte Gabon c'est des états comme
la Caroline du Nord par exemple le
Tennessee et même plus proche de nous
l'Ontario et avec Line fléchis réduction
Act aux États-Unis mais là le
gouvernement il voit à coup de
subventions pour attirer ses entreprises
là faites là on se dit qu'ici au Québec
l'incitatif que nous on peut avoir c'est
justement l'énergie renouvelable parce
que les multinationales en 2023 veulent
se donner bonne conscience ils veulent
produire vers dans le fond donc c'est un
argument de taille moi ce que j'ai
trouvé ce matin c'est que monsieur
Legault se faisait l'écho de ce que j'ai
entendu la semaine dernière alors que je
faisais des appels pour en savoir plus
sur ce qui s'était passé entre madame
Brochu monsieur Fitz gibben monsieur
Legault puis souvent la semaine dernière
dans mes appels je suis tombé sur des
gens qui étaient un peu frustré des
journalistes des chroniques des
entrevues même des caricatures des
analyses qui disait vous faites légères
en descra vous le savez pas ce qui s'est
passé dans la tête de Madame Brochu vous
savez pas vraiment ce qui s'est passé
derrière des porte-closes dans nos
discussions alors que la réalité c'est
que l'éthique journalistique commande
que quand on a des sources qui nous
parlent lorsqu'on a des informations
qu'on recoupe on est capable d'aller
faire certaines affirmations en or mais
visiblement ils étaient pas contents
monsieur Legault s'est fait l'écho de ça
aujourd'hui puis effectivement son lait
à lui c'est d'être un développeur point
pas un développeur à la solde des
multinationales là je pense qu'ils
commencent à sentir que la pente devient
le message que il y a pas pour reprendre
une expression les Québécois un peu plus
âgés connaissent ils voulaient pas la
tonne de faire à Saint-Seine là il
voulait pas donner l'image qu'elle est
bazarder l'électricité au plus aux
entreprises pour trois fois rien puis
rien recevoir en retour mais dans sa
logique de développement Michel coog
monsieur LEGO a besoin de développer la
capacité hydraulique du Québec parce que
si on veut attirer toutes ces
entreprises là entre autres puis on veut
continuer à se développer il va manquer
d'énergie là arrive la volonté de
développer le côté castor dont parlait
ce fibrochure
oui mais ce qu'on entend pas dans la
bouche de monsieur Legault c'est de dire
on va essayer d'économiser l'énergie ça
coûte probablement même certainement
moins cher que de bâtir de nouvelles
centrales électriques parce que vous
avez entendu le premier du Québec qui a
la juridiction de le faire dire on va
changer le code du bâtiment nos fenêtres
aucune des principales sources de perte
d'énergie pour rien
il peut faire ça et c'est quelque chose
qui lui est demandé par beaucoup de gens
y compris par Madame reçu d'ailleurs il
ne l'a pas fait on entend jamais parler
d'économie d'énergie de la part du
Premier ministre c'est comme si ça
n'existait pas et que la seule façon
d'augmenter la capacité électrique du
Québec c'était de bâtir de nouveaux
barrages et c'est ça qui est le problème
c'est qu'il regarde juste une partie de
l'équation et l'autre c'est comme si
elle n'existait pas et mais l'avocat du
diable Émilie répondrait que même si on
est si on avait une note parfaite dans
l'économie d'énergie ce qui n'est pas le
cas actuellement et je va falloir
connaître mais même si on allait on
avait une note parfaite viendra un jour
pas si loin éteint où on aura peut-être
besoin d'augmenter notre capacité de
production c'est ça qui dit mais en fait
c'est la tête de Monsieur le veau là
tout à fait puis quand on voit dans le
plan stratégique du gros Québec qui
avait été développé notamment par sophie
Brochu on voit que pour augmenter la
capacité de production ce qu'on mettait
de l'avance surtout c'est augmenter
l'efficacité des centrales donc des
mises à jour technologiques augmenter le
secteur de l'éolien puis vraiment
développer ça puis développer le solaire
aussi donc développer les autres sources
d'énergie renouvelables en plus
d'augmenter la capacité de
d'Hydro-Québec ensuite c'est sûr que je
comprends lorsqu'il dit en fait il y a
pas de d'écart d'une personne qui
travaille pour l'étranger une personne
qui travaille pour les intérêts du
Québec sont donc pour les intérêts du
Québec c'est c'est habile comme
communication je pense que ça ce que ça
sous-entend peut-être que ce que ça
gomme c'est que c'est pas tout le monde
au Québec à la même vision que de ce que
ça veut dire travailler dans l'intérêt
du Québec en fait donc lorsqu'on pense
que en tout cas il y a une vision du
développement économique qui est taxé
sur effectivement les entreprises puis
je pense d'ailleurs que François Legault
a dit aujourd'hui que dans ton travail
avec certains entreprises pour lui c'est
dans l'intérêt du Québec puis ça peut
être tout à fait dans un certain cas
mais c'est là où je pense qu'il y a des
accords sur il y a des désaccords sur le
degré par laquelle l'intérêt du Québec
passe par ces entreprises là et l'action
on peut pas à communication faire
semblant que c'est des accords-là existe
pas et je pense que c'est ce débat là
qu'on va continuer à avoir dans les
prochaines semaines parce que Véronique
et Monsieur faitgaben et Monsieur Lego
ont répété à plusieurs reprises depuis
le départ de sophie Brochu qui avait pas
vraiment deux visions mais il y a des
degrés de différents madame Brochu en
entrevue m'avait donné il y a quelques
mois une image assez efficace en disant
avant de bâtir des nouveaux barrages
chez comme acheter des autobus scolaires
il faut s'assurer que les autobus
scolaires qu'on a soit plein à craquer
avant d'en acheter un neuf et elle
s'était sa logique de dire je refuse pas
le développement éventuellement mais
avant d'aller là il y a plusieurs étapes
qu'on n'a pas encore franchi et c'est là
où monsieur Legault est peut-être plus
pressé le soyons francs là c'est là les
différences de
non pas de vision carrément mais de oui
de rythme
divergence de vision lui ne voit
actuellement comme solution à ça que de
partir de nouvelles centrales on en est
peut-être pas là on a même pas regardé
sérieusement l'autre partie c'est ça qui
est moi je trouve incompréhensible et
c'est pour ça que j'utilisais dans une
expression comme plus
la solution c'est toujours on va passer
le nouvel centrale mais on ne va pas
regarder les choses peut-être coûte
moins cher
mais Véronique dans les plans qu'ils ont
eux sont convaincus que ça va prendre
une augmentation de la production
oui absolument c'est oui parce que plus
tu vas attirer des entreprises ici puis
même si par exemple on produit de
l'aluminium vert ce genre de choses là
elles vont avoir besoin d'électricité
justement pour opérer cette transition
là puis plus elles vont avoir besoin
d'électricité à ce moment-là plus il va
falloir en produire alors que la logique
peut-être plus de Madame Brochu c'est
d'en produire mais de manière plus
efficace à ce qu'on doit regarder ça
davantage ça veut pas dire que le
gouvernement logo n'était pas d'accord
avec ce qu'avant si justement le plan du
gros-québec par contre quand vous dites
qu'ils sont pressés oui on le sent
qu'ils sont pressés parce que
premièrement c'est dans la personnalité
de monsieur Legault de Monsieur fidubn
probablement à cause de leurs
antécédents d'hommes d'affaires mais
aussi tout le monde sait ici que c'est
peut-être le dernier manga ne demanda de
François Legault parce que l'histoire
veut que ce serait quand même surprenant
un troisième mandat en tout cas ça
pourrait être un exploit alors si
effectivement c'est le dernier mandat à
ce moment là ils vouloir laisser quelque
chose derrière eux dans les livres
d'histoire et il faut l'avancer le plus
possible très bien ok alors on va on va
en reparler et les rencontres en passant
avec les chefs d'opposition s'inscrivent
un peu dans cette dans cette optique là
je disais on passe à notre sujet mais je
vais rester parce que je trouve ça trop
intéressant trop intéressant
les rencontres avec les chefs
d'opposition c'est comme Monsieur le
groupe voulait
sortir un peu de la mêlée et dire
j'écoute toutes les tendances et dans le
fond je travaille pour tous les
Québécois mais c'est notre grande
richesse l'hydroélectricité il joue
beaucoup là-dessus
on touche à des mythes fondateurs de la
Révolution tranquille et donc l'idée que
les Québécois sont tous ensemble et
qu'ils au Québec c'est un fleuron c'est
pour ça je parlais tout à l'heure au
niveau de la communication je pense que
c'est pas facile mais c'est faisable au
niveau de la communication de faire
semblant qu'on est tous d'accord qu'on
va tous dans le même sens et qu'on est
tous de Québécois etc etc alors que il y
a des différences claires entre c'est
quoi la stratégie de développement
est-ce qu'on insiste sur les entreprises
où est-ce qu'on insiste sur la sécurité
énergétique des Québécois d'abord est-ce
que l'exportation est si importante que
ça ce que rattrapé l'Ontario est
important que ça si oui comment est-ce
qu'on fait tous ces désaccords là
existent mais je m'adresse que François
Legault continue dans le discours à
sonner plus rassembleur que ces idées ne
sont peut-être vous avez raison
d'ajouter ça parce que Véronique et
Michel ça revient depuis jour 1 de son
entrée en politique monsieur Legault
veut rattraper le niveau de richesse de
l'Ontario alors parce que vous posez la
bonne question Amélie vous dites est-ce
que c'est nécessaire d'attirer tant
d'entreprises que ça pense que c'est
nécessaire développement mais si on est
dans une optique où on veut rattraper la
richesse collective de l'Ontario ce qui
est pas en soi le mauvaise idée là mais
bon il faut faire ça vers un excès
soleil tout est lié dans leur esprit là
ouais mais moi on m'a dit c'est pas tant
plusieurs entreprises qu'on veut attirer
c'est pas nécessairement des petits
joueurs qu'on veut aussi au contraire
c'est des gros joueurs des gros joueurs
qui vont changer le profil d'une région
on parlait de la filière batterie dans
le reportage hier donc qui vont non
seulement changer une région mais qui
vont apporter des revenus pour cette
région là qui vont être très très
important donc c'est les gros joueurs
qu'on veut attirer et pour ça comme je
le dis l'initiatif principal pourquoi il
viendrait au Québec plutôt qu'aux
États-Unis en Amérique du Nord ils
veulent ils veulent réduire leur
dépendance à la Chine mais pourquoi
venir au Québec plutôt qu'ailleurs ben
l'incitatif principal c'est dire on a
cette ressource là non
très bien
transfère en santé on va passer sur
l'hôpital maisonneuve-rosement je pense
qu'on a tout dit Monsieur LEGO a répété
ce matin lors de ce point de presse qui
manque d'infirmière je pense que je
pense qu'on s'en était aperçu que les
gens ne laissent de Montréal surtout
transfert en santé on va écouter
monsieur Legault et Monsieur Trudeau
puis on revient rapidement ensuite
j'ai rencontré Justin Trudeau je vous ai
dit que j'étais plus optimiste que
jamais ce que j'ai compris de ma
rencontre avec Justin Trudeau c'est
qu'on ne parlait plus de conditions mais
on parlait de donner
on sait aussi que le Québec et champion
pour les données grâce entre autres à
Christian Dubé qui a un tableau de bord
très détaillé c'est peut-être pas le cas
d'autres provinces nous évidemment que
les données qu'on rend déjà public on
n'a pas de problème mais les envoyer à
ta voix
il reste encore du travail à faire mais
on sent qu'il y a un
momentum très positif parce qu'on
s'aligne de plus en plus pour des
investissements dans les systèmes de
santé mais soyons très clairs les
investissements dont on est en train de
parler avec le fédéral c'est des
investissements pour assurer le moyen
terme le long terme
de l'amélioration de nos systèmes de
santé oui il y a besoin de
maintenant mais ça à ce niveau là les
provinces ont la capacité fiscale
d'investir tout de suite dans les
besoins de tous les jours qu'on a
maintenant
répète puis nous l'avait dit en fin
d'année puis il avait dit à peu près à
tout le monde répète que à court terme
là ils ont l'argent s'ils veulent le
faire investir beaucoup beaucoup mais ça
long terme dont on parle et des deux
côtés encore une fois on joue sur les
mots mais on a enlevé le mot condition
pour des raisons évidentes on parle de
transparence on parle de données
Véronique on s'approche quoi d'une vraie
entente
on dirait que oui en tout cas la lumière
des propos de Monsieur logo en même
temps j'ai trouvé intéressant une
portion de la conférence de presse où il
y a un journaliste qui lui a dit bon
vous êtes d'accord pour rendre les
données disponibles l'Ontario est
d'accord si les autres provinces sont
pas d'accord est-ce que ça veut dire que
l'Ontario et le Québec vont briser le
front commun monsieur LEGO a répondu ben
là on est quand même les deux provinces
les plus populaires en laissant entendre
que les autres vont suivre si nous on
décide ça mais après ça il a dit non le
front commun est intact ça nous a
toujours servi pour voir on va le garder
intact ce seront là très bien Émilie
en fait c'est la question des conditions
je comprends que ici c'est pour un
enfant de réflexe politique la plupart
des gens qui observent ceux qui vont
dans le même sens que François Legault
sur le fait que ça prend pas je trouve
ça vraiment intéressant pour moi de
regarder le débat la manière dont tu
fais ailleurs par exemple en Ontario ou
il y a un réflexe très réflexe ou
quelque chose est important pour que ça
soit le mercenaire donc Ottawa qui
s'emmène donc je suis je suis curieuse
de voir comment ça va passer dans
l'opinion publique en fait si c'est
adapté sans condition surtout que le
débat est relancé par d'autres joyeux 5
minutes de la santé cette semaine qui
parlait de la place du privé en santé et
que bon la loi sur la santé au Canada
garantit la place du public là-dedans
donc s'il y a des gouvernements
provinciaux qui se mettent à faire plus
de place au privé dans la santé le fait
que je l'entende pas sans condition ça
peut rebondir aussi sur je fais un truc
donc ça va être à voir aussi dans les
prochaines semaines dans les prochains
mois très bien Michel quelques
on entend plus le mot d'ordre national
parce que Monsieur Trudeau est dans un
gouvernement minoritaire à la vertu du
NPD qui aime pas attaquer qui n'aime pas
trop ce qu'il voit il va et le pignon
public je veux qu'on mette de l'argent
sur la table en santé monsieur Trudeau
ne sent très bien alors c'est pour ça
que tout le monde est en train de mettre
un peu dans le dos dans son verre comme
ça de convergence le pignon public est
très puissante là-dedans très bien merci
beaucoup Véronique Michel et Émilie
merci à très bientôt au revoir